5 14 it is that time again to gift
someone a good day 8 news now has
partnered with albertsons to help make
someone's day a little bit brighter boy
this was fun let's take a look
i met jeannie at the albertsons on
rainbow in charleston she said her check
no longer covers her bills and she has
to get creative to make ends meet i
noticed the coupons those are important
right now extremely
every little bit counts
it helps
it's
does my sunning that's when eight news
now and albertsons decided to give her a
surprise we would like to make your day
a little bit better
eight news now in albertson's we like to
gift you a good day and take care of
your groceries today oh thank you what a
blessing
a true true blessing we're happy to be
able to do this for you can i hug you of
course
thank you
oh i'm so happy for you couldn't find a
more deserving person
you have no idea
no idea what this means
you have made my day my prayers are
answered
god is good
god is good well
channel 8 albertson's we're trying to
trying to make a difference as much as
we can oh you did
i was feeling so
down well
thank you
thank you channel 8.
there's a smile under that mask i know
it
[Music]
beautiful beautiful genie
you're very welcome
i had such a good time surprising
jeannie and getting to know her thanks
again to albertsons for making this all
happen you never know you could be next
jeannie was so sweet she sent us a thank
you note and said you know because of
this gift she's now she and her family
are going to have easter dinner oh no
kidding so and she's paying it forward
her neighbors are yeah
yes so just a wonderful woman i mean
we've met so many incredible people
through this process and and real i
think just getting into the community
and seeing the need out there is much
greater than i think any one person can
help but every little bit counts